a controversial Netflix series is
causing schools to warn parents about
the risk of teen suicide school
districts across the country in out
sending letters home about the new show
it's called 13 reasons why it's a
fictional story is about a 17 year old
girl who takes her own life the themes
are graphic and intense Netflix says
that it is intended for mature audiences
because of its explicit and disturbing
content and that is a warning that we
now share with you - Tony - copal is
here with the concerns Tony good morning
good morning the show tackle is not only
suicide but also sexual assault and
underage drinking now Netflix says it
hopes the show provides an opening to
difficult conversations but educators
and parents are concerned that 13
reasons why might be glamorizing teen
suicide
hey it's Hanna the Netflix series is
narrated by teenager Hannah Baker a
troubled high school student who has
recorded a series of audio tapes
describing the 13 reasons why she has
taken her own life and if you're
listening to this tape you're one of the
reasons why the program's unflinching
look at teen suicide is causing concern
among school districts nationwide
they're sending letters to parents
warning the show may be perceived as
glorifying and romanticizing suicide
suicide is a tough issue to talk about
dr. Christina Connelly works for
Maryland's Montgomery County school
district where she helped write a letter
saying adolescents watching without an
adult could be at increased risk of
self-harm watching a suicide or knowing
someone who has died by suicide can lead
others to completing a suicide
themselves Netflix responded to the
concerns in a statement we gave the
series a tv-ma rating and added explicit
warnings on the three most graphic
episodes we hope that 13 reasons why can
serve as a catalyst for conversation
bring your kids to work day go radio
hosts Toby Knapp received a warning
letter from his 13 year old daughter
Kyla school but only after she had
already binge dois ch 13 reasons why
alone it's caused her mom and I to say
okay what is our daughter watching what
is she spending her screen time on
none of you cared enough I think it's
all too real
for most of people my age to cope with
and understand the series is designed to
have an intense impact on viewers
according to executive producer Selena
Gomez who herself struggled with
depression they have to see something
that's going to shake them this show is
as real as it possibly could get a real
show leading to real family dialogue I'm
glad we're having a lot of tough
conversations but I wish I would have
been tuned into those conversations
sooner
now however these conversations between
parents and their children get started
they are very important according to the
American Academy of Pediatrics among
American teens aged 15 to 19 the second
leading cause of death is suicide
Nora oh wow Toni thank you it's an
interesting discussion to have yeah I'm
glad it's generating the conversation as
difficult as it is to hear and think
about right and if your child is
interested in this series it's good to
have a discussion about why that's right